[Music]
welcome back to dirty arty chapter 25
the season finale we're no longer in
fallout 3 Jake were back in Red Dead
Redemption - and it's our plan to end
out this series with it to end it with a
nice little bang how we're gonna do that
well yeah tie up loose ends in order to
in order for it to be a strong finale
we're gonna go back and play some the
best characters and aliases that dirty
already has has taken on himself and
we're gonna yeah we're gonna kill them
off and we're gonna close the - all the
timelines close all the timelines that's
it starting with that was a good one
so where should we go first that's a
good question maybe maybe a mmm
Pigman Pigman it is I feel like pig
man's one of my favorites and we haven't
seen Pigman in a while I see paper
that's right the big man big man is back
well why don't we head in the sand Denis
as the pig man and see what kind of
trouble we can cause I'm game
remember his calling card though that's
right
gotta have his calling card that's right
big man's back dari was dead but you
were wrong there's no one on that yes oh
wow
oh my god I'm stuck
[Music]
come on I gotta be quick there it is
that's how they know it was me
look another can house a pig in the
millet street really is my brother
don't hurt my pig
what a sick take on skin oh oh you
scared my brother he's killing his own
kind he's sick someone put him down
that pig just killed another pig very
indecisive all you wanted to do with
that [ __ ] we lost some hope it's a can
of beans I hate this way mistrial this
way gotta make them think they're safe
[Laughter]
mind before you blow it out
and that is how the Pigman died dead gay
killed by a gator I think it's only
fitting gator kills the pig Gator kill
Pig holy [ __ ] is that cat man I thought
he was a myth wanted I wanted who's
Arthur Morgan I don't know that is I
heard he's a rather good looking guy
though oh my god my bounty is over 1100
don't you me get out of my way he was
selling drugs
I don't know what he's doing think you
have me card but you know you don't
thank you that you would have to be so
exhausted
Oh another timeline wrapped up another
one dead another one bites the dust
[Music]
cap all right
this isn't his ship though this is just
the skiff to his other ship correct
which he hasn't stolen yet I found yet
we need a crew and I think I know how we
can get one oh my head this is gonna
hurt yeah you're you're you're great I
like you you're gonna come on this boat
you got that fighting spirit I like it
quit your cryin we got a friend pirate
already got a friend I could die happy
now
comfortable he's not moving that our
friend died already again another one
nope sorry this ain't happening
get your ass back here oh wow sank right
to the body didn't know what to do oh
well that's a bummer I got a present for
you no don't family business circle
button oh let you do it well [ __ ] well
we've got a little fleet here oh no no
well my pirate Hannah captain always
goes down with your ship goodbye cruel
world
Oh miss fast musty Marston musty Mart
I didn't even press anything he just
yelled scare what's he doing he's just
staring at a wall look at the right he's
throwing up greet okay friend enjoy the
time you got left
I'm past being hurt by some words nice
one-two punch hell yeah
another day what are you doing he's
doing the chicken day
oh yeah we did get yeah say it again say
it boys
say it it's definitely the same actor we
said it all right well alright to the
graveyard
alright well it's not as opposed as it
gets to though Jesus Christ oh good god
no say it you are hearing nothing I like
you okay another time line closes dead
and now yeah big fella now we're going
to Valentine me to imagine just sitting
down the guy flies from the floor just
eats [ __ ] just like you guys do any work
yeah that good ol valentine mud get much
better than this no listen it I need the
gun in order to get dirty it's a weird
thing with me I have to have an arm
makes me feel comfortable all the
sheriff
[Music]
I finally did it
oh my god of course nice beaver you got
up there that's the same gotcha I see it
well this might be the end of the road
This Is It this is it musical chime well
it's been real there we go tell me
forward a little bit 360s there a now
it's time for show us your Artie where
you guys send in your own creations and
interpretations of dirty Artie got a
strong one for the first one from Alfred
Palmer I love it and he made another one
for Artie but he made one for John as
well these are these are gifts yeah I
mean I know once again it'll blink and
then if you see oh good god no no let's
love it and there's another one sent in
another one already in space
that's exactly how it went down well
that's awesome
alfred palmer and thank you for that one
that's fantastic space already ding this
one's from our Nertz or something like
that
but yeah this one's pretty cool that
good Valentine mud hell yeah fly we've
covered that in the finale
good old Valentine that is super menace
sick awesome this is from art Morgan he
sent us a bunch but I only put I pick
two of my fav
so this batch and this was one of them I
like the dramatic peek through the
through the wood going boo boo
well then here's another one from him
where he's setting a little house on
fire as John I believe yeah cuz look at
that hat he was pretty good he said he
he only gave himself like ten minutes to
draw this or whatever and he was like it
looks pretty bad I'm like it does but
also it like I mean it's it's it's
already style you know yeah for sure
like I think I think there's something
to be said for like the quick and ugly
drawings of Arthur more yeah I love them
I think they're great
I love awesome too yeah it's from my co
Tron 1980 apparently the town ran out of
beans so I'm down there's their graves
apparently somebody on that also dirty
that horses dirty ass horse was thinking
about that's awesome and that one's from
McKenna current Oh
vote for Lady rights ones and our
women's rights and then there's classic
Arthur Morgan with a gang the police hat
she does not look at me does not
thinking up her space that's awesome
that's pretty good mmm rat killer Keller
yeah rat killer Keller whoa
rebby the W threw this one in there
because it looked pretty menacing and
okay you call it dynamite don't have
much time to figure that out though I'm
not doing here
but yeah shooting that guy right in the
eye
is leaving his skull yes it is nice Mogi
yes I made a little Arthur emoji RJ the
pro I thought we had to include that he
has a watch for some reason that's
awesome it's pretty cool oh and this is
from sock animates and it was very
adorable Artie aka being like it's like
cool font and then look he's got all
that beans
alright last one is it that is the last
show us your Artie damn
the final one well it's sad to end it
but I think I think we've done our job
25 episodes 25 and they have been a
blast they have been a blast for sure
and we would not have been able to have
done all those without you guys for
watching so thank you so much for
letting us get this far and for all your
submissions and all your awesome
comments yeah and stay tuned to game
spot we're always gonna be trying to do
interesting cool things like this when
we can yeah we had no intention of this
last thing as long as it did we figured
I'll do a couple episodes yeah and no
one would watch it but turns out a lot
of people watch that a lot of people
really liked it for sure and it's been
an absolute blast yeah has been I think
you know you know you and I have been
talking about it we do plan on doing
something similar we were thinking about
you know when the time comes outer
worlds yeah outer worlds could be a good
one maybe cyberpunk way down the line
cyberpunk will be a perfect one for this
and bring back the dirty arty or form of
him yeah but that's gonna do it then
thank you guys again so much for
watching and we'll see it all on another
series
you